so hello my name is Jonathan Moore so
Who am I my background is I did a PhD in
astrophysics in 2011 from University
California San Diego I went on to do a
postdoc in astre in Australia in
astrophysics in 2014 I did Incitatus
science fellowship in 2014 and after
that I started working as a data
scientist in Silicon Valley data science
I also did an O'Reilly screencast course
called Jupiter notebook for data science
teams which is a little icon there in
the lower right so this is my background
I'll be talking to you about mental
models to be using in data science so
here's a quote from Fineman which I
think everyone it was a scientist or
data scientist can resonate with very
well the first principle of science or
trying to discover knowledge about the
world is that you must not fool yourself
and you'll you yourself are the easiest
person to fool I think that's that's
very appropriate and very true so I'm
going to start off with a few I call it
mental models for lack of a more
concrete term it's more of an umbrella
term for strategies that people use and
they should be avoiding and also making
sure to try to incorporate into their
own practice so some things to avoid pee
hacking so pee hacking everyone knows
pee hacking if you don't know pee
hacking I'll explain it in just one
second but pee hacking fishing
expeditions and researchers degrees of
freedom these are all relative to the
same kind of phenomenon as best
explained by a comic from xkcd
so the comic begins jelly beans cause
acne and asking for scientists to
investigate this hypothesis and they
come back and they say we found no link
between jelly beans and acne with the
p-value of less than 0.05 and I think
that settles it but then someone says no
actually I think it's a certain color of
jelly beans that causes acne not just
jelly beans in general so they go off
and they start testing individual color
for jelly beans so they say we find no
link between the purple jelly beans
and acne no link between brown jelly
beans and acne no link between pink so
on and so forth
end up doing 20 different comparisons
and lo and behold this one in the
upper-right second to the right panel
says we found a link between green
jellybeans and acne so they did 20
different tests and the news of course
reports green nack trading jellybeans
are linked to acne with a 95 percent
confidence only a 5% chance of
coincidence all right so that's pee
hacking everyone loves to point at that
and say clearly that's wrong we
shouldn't be doing that and I think
people who are aware of this might be
lulled into a false sense of security
about their own analysis so let's look
at look at one that's slightly more
subtle than this egregious case and it's
one that's found in the wild so here is
a paper then it's called gender bias an
open source a pull request
pull request of acceptance of women
versus men as in this peer peer J link
I'd like to make a couple of caveats
before I begin first of all this was
submitted for comments so I'm actually
I'm actually gonna be commenting on the
one that's submitted for comments and
there's multiple versions of this after
this so this is you tend to be thought
of as first draft feedback and so I'm
using just this first draft for didactic
reasons and it's currently not peer
reviewed so with those two caveats out
of the way their analytical setup was
actually really interesting there in
examining github commits they had over 4
million github profiles with users and
email addresses they identified the
gender of over 1.4 million of these
users they also had access to 2.3
million
merged poll requests now if you're not
familiar but pull requests are there
basically you suggest code improvements
or additions to some project and if it's
accepted and it's an emerge into the
project poll requests and the research
question is relatively well defined is
there a gender bias in poll requests
acceptance rates so the first question
that they addressed in the paper is our
women's poll requests less likely to be
accepted the hypothesis is yes it's
probably that they're less likely to be
accepted and when they did the
statistical test on this their results
showed that
actually no to a very small p-value it
looks like women's merge requests are
actually higher significantly than men
and so they thought this was strange so
they had a second question maybe sorry
did you see that yeah okay what if we
exclude insiders from our analysis so
insiders are these explicitly authorized
owners and collaborators of a specific
open-source project and outsource
outsiders are other github users and
they found that it continues to be a
significantly higher acceptance rate
than men and so they go on and ask well
maybe well request acceptance rates to
start low and then they end up very high
and the people who keep committing are
the high acceptance rate so that's
what's skewing the overall balance and
so along the y-axis here you see the
acceptance rate of the different genders
the top one is women versus men and the
lower one the x-axis is pole requests
that have been offered and it's a
logarithmic scale for the first one is
all the way on the left and it goes the
first the second the fourth the eighth
the sixteenth and so on all the way
along the x-axis so you can see that
even from the very first commit the
first commit that a woman gives versus
the first commit that a man gives it
tends to have a higher acceptance rate
and so they go through actually many
many more of these so I'll just briefly
show you their conclusions part so the
the observations of the paper that is
reporting says women are more likely
have poor requests except for the men
that continue to have high acceptance
rates as they gain experience they are
less likely to serve an immediate
project need this was done in actually
some cool way
women's changes tend to be larger
women's acceptance rates are higher
across the top 10 programming languages
that work on github and then they found
and the sixth one is that women have
lower acceptance rates as outsiders when
they identify as women so that was the
the sixth and final observation on this
draft one of this paper so the plot for
that one comes from here so the left
plot is insiders and outsiders as are
insiders and whether their github
username or picture was gender neutral
and whether it was gendered was the
first split and on the right
his outsiders who have gender-neutral
versus gendered get github emojis
avatars and the actual difference
between the men and the women in the
gendered Outsiders isn't statistically
significant but if you compare the women
to the gender neutral in the outsiders
that is connect significant so you think
back about to the the P hacking scenario
where if you keep making many many
comparisons multiple comparisons
eventually you will find something that
either you'll find a value that's
significant first of all or if you have
hypotheses in mind you can also end on
that kind of a thing as well there's
actually an interesting sub story in
this as well in the so it was submitted
for comment for commentary their
question was asked do you have data on
the gender of the users that are
accepting the poll requests and the
author replied to this one of the
authors so our analysis which wasn't
included in this paper that was for that
which we've cut out a lot shows that
women are harder on other women than
they are in men and men are harder on
other men than they are on women which
is kind of an interesting sub story to
have one of the things I was also led to
point out is that they've cut out a lot
of analysis so they've actually done
many many more comparisons than they
already showed in the paper so they're
doing is multiple comparison multiple
comparisons problem is definitely a
concern that should be raised there's
some statistical ways of dealing with
this with like a bonferroni correction
or something else but even then I'll get
to why that might not be enough in just
a little bit of course in just the same
way that the P hacking xkcd scenario
showed how the media overreact to this
or reacts in an interesting way the the
media was lust nuanced than the paper
itself when the Business Insider was
like sexism is rampant among programmers
and github and they linked directly to
the study so media has their own agendas
of course so yes it's interesting so you
can see how this you could consider the
second one more of a fishing expedition
we just keep pulling back comparisons
out until you find a comparison that
you've is what you're looking for or
something that's compelling or
you think is publishable right okay so
there's another flavor of this same
category that I think is important to
bring up so it's easy at this point for
people our scientists to think okay well
I've not done
the p-value one that was clearly
obviously wrong and probably not doing
anything like the second one either so I
think I'm probably on solid ground
there's this very very good paper by
Andrew Gelman and I'm Thomas I'm going
to pronounce his name it called the
Garden of forking paths and the title of
the paper is actually the conclusion as
well so I'll go through the title slowly
the Garden of forking paths why multiple
comparisons the thing we were just
talking about can be a problem even when
there is no fishing expedition or pea
hacking and the research hypothesis was
posited ahead of time so saying there's
still a problem of multiple comparisons
even if you have all these other things
taken care of so here's an etheric
example that they gave so imagine you'd
like to test the difference between
Democrats and Republicans and your
giving you grant do this test by giving
a math test in two different contexts
health care and military the hypothesis
being that context matters and one would
expect Democrats to do better in health
care context and Republicans to do
better in the military context so this
is just a hypothetical example so
already you can ask the question how
many options for results are there so
number of patterns that could be found
among men but not among women there is a
difference between the Republicans and
Democrats and this math test which could
be explicable under the theory that men
are more ideologically driven than women
or it could be found among women but not
among men so this is explicable under
the theory that women are more sensitive
to context or there could be a
difference it could be between the sexes
in the healthcare context but not within
the military context and and so on and
so forth so there's many possible
comparisons even if you already have the
research question stated ahead of time
so the conclusion that they have
research or degrees of freedom can lead
to a multiple comparisons problem even
settings where researchers perform only
a single analysis
their data the problem is a fundamental
one and it comes from that there is a
large number of potential comparisons
when the details of data analysis are
highly contingent on the data without
the researcher having to perform any
conscious procedure of fishing fishing
or examining multiple p-values okay so
going on to another topic just so
storytelling this is this is a rampant
in research as well as in business where
the basic idea is you explain the data
with a plausible sounding story after
you know what the answer is so once you
know the answer then you say okay that
makes sense because and then you go on
with your explanation so this is also
known as harking from this paper and
1998
so it's hypothesizing after the results
are known so this is a this is a hard
one to avoid especially if you have if
you're interacting with say managers or
someone who is not trained and even
people who are trained but especially if
they're not trained in science or
statistics that they would like to they
like to have come up with stories after
the fact and it helps to essentially try
to force them before you tell the answer
make your hypothesis what would if I
told you the answer was X what would
that tell you if I've told you it was
not X what would that tell you and
forcing them to solidify their thoughts
on this matter before they know that
results is one way you can help avoid
this just so storytelling problem any
questions so far before I go into the
next section all right sorry I did a lot
of examples on what not to use yes
yes yeah so Simpsons paradox is one
where there's an overall trend that can
even reverse sign if you actually take
into account the the various
subcategories so I have one of the
things I'm gonna say in this to use will
hopefully start to address that if it
hasn't asked me again at the end and
I'll come back sure okay the question
was this sounds in some ways the
opposite of Simpsons paradox right and
okay so I said a lot of things to avoid
things to be wary of things to be
concerned about so here are some things
I recommend you using so there's a
strategy called consider the opposite so
this is this comes from a number of
papers but the one I'm citing here is
called the source of it is consider the
opposite a corrective strategy for
social judgment where they actually
tested whether they asked people to make
a judgment on a specific thing like the
height of someone or whatever and they
gave them two different ways say like
please be as unbiased as possible be as
fair as possible and go and then the
other group of people they said consider
the opposite of the hypothesis you
currently have so if you think that
there let's say shorter than someone
else consider maybe they're actually
taller and as long as it's kept to a
reasonable number of alternative
hypotheses so like a couple rather than
like 50 this apparently has a better
corrective strategy than just
emphasizing people please be on there my
bias please be fair so considering the
opposite just helps you get closer to
the correct answer than the reverse
asking yourself this question which I
alluded to a little bit earlier which
what-what would change your mind
specifically let's say you have a belief
a about the world so frame it as
hypothesis a is how the world works so
ask yourself and encourage others to ask
you what would it look like if your
hypothesis were wrong for a hypothetical
case this is a way of getting at
falsifiability but you say okay let's
say assume it's wrong and what do I mean
by that so let's just go through
example so let's say your hypothesis was
that every action anybody ever takes
ever he's done for selfish self selfish
reasons so I do a thought experiment and
challenge it in this way so say for the
sake of argument Alice actually did an
unselfish act so we're in this
hypothetical realm where we had a person
who actually did something that was
unselfish how would you recognize that
this just happened and that your
hypothesis is is incorrect in this case
if the answer is nothing if there is
nothing that you could do to figure out
that your hypothesis got this wrong then
your hypothesis is unverifiable in
principle which is different than
unfalsifiable in practice but the basic
problem with that is that your
explanation has zero explanatory power
even getting it wrong looks like you got
it right so if you can't do this kind of
thing this is one easy litmus test to
say okay I need to think about a little
bit more carefully about how I could
what would change my mind
some sort of evidence that would look
like X Y or Z okay so I'd like to go
into another study that was done on the
rates of red cards being given to
players so this paper that comes from
this paper here which is called many
analysts one data set making transparent
how variations and analytical choices
affect results so they crowd-sourced
their analysis they put out a call for a
proposal for analysts to do some
analysis on some data that they had they
gave everyone every team of analysts the
same data they gave them the same exact
research question so our soccer referees
more likely to give red cards to dark
skin toned players than light skin tone
players so they have a specific research
question the same data set and they had
29 research teams composed of 61 total
analysts going back to the multiple
comparisons problems and analytic
choices that are being made
so everyone has to use because you're
trying to say what is the effect of skin
tone on red card
getting red cards you have to choose
covariates in the data some other
variable that you're also going to
consider in this analysis so here is a
plot of the different covariance that
were available so along the x-axis you
see the player's position their height
their weight their age which lead
country they're in and so on and many
different choices here and along the
x-axis if there's a black square there
that team that team number along the top
used that covariant so the the covariate
that was most commonly used was
positioned and only 62% of the team's
chose it and then from there on out you
can see this so people made many many
different choices on which covariates to
use and this was actually done in a
really cool way that they did a
round-robin style thing so they first
gave everyone the data the research
question they did an analysis wrote the
analysis got an answer and submitted all
of their results back to us the central
author who then took away the results
and collated everyone's research that
they'd done so far and put it back out
to all the remaining teams for feedback
so I got a second round of eternal peer
review basically saying here's what I
think you should do better here's what
not and everyone gave reasons for why
they're including or not including these
covariates and they're all very
reasonable sounding like oh I shouldn't
use you know position because of X Y or
Z why not and instill here the different
analytic approaches that were used this
is just a su min of a few of them so one
analytic approach was 0 inflated Poisson
regression
another one was Bayesian logistic
regression we have hierarchical log
linear modeling multi-level regression
so many different ways of attacking this
problem and the results here's a 538 the
the political blogs a visualization of
this paper result shows so equally
likely is that the thick black line
along the bottom here if I along the
bottom there's a equally likely between
light skin and dark skin tone players to
get a red card and whether it's
significant or not
and the odds ratio going it's more
likely that a dark-skinned player is to
get a red card is farther up and the
error bar sizes change
drastically the results change between
significant not significant the basic
conclusions are this so note teams found
a negative effect that it went the
opposite way than expected nine teams
found no significant relationship
whatsoever and twenty teams found a
positive effect so they said this is
from their paper directly selecting
randomly from the present teams there
would have been a 69% probability of
reporting a positive result in a 31%
probability of reporting a null effect
this raises the possibility that many
research projects contain hidden
uncertainty due to the wide range of
analytic choices available to the
researchers so this hopefully doesn't
just make you disheartened about what
can science and teach us about anything
but it is something to be aware of like
so this was done as carefully as
possible this was definitely not in
multiple comparisons problem people were
choosing it in different contexts
entirely and getting peer review before
they even released it and still they had
results ranging across this entire
effect size so it should be at least
somewhat sobering so one way to help
address this problem is something called
blinding analysis now you might have
heard of double blinding so double blind
studies are the the gold standard and in
clinical trials and whatnot so it's
where the experimenter and subject
neither one knows who's getting a
placebo was getting the actual drug and
so on and that's not what I'm talking
about when I say blinding analysis so
blinding analysis is essentially a
principle more than it is a technique
and the principle is do not let the
expectation of a particular result drive
model revision this comes from it was I
guess popularized in particle physics
where they have a long history of this
of being self-critical of what they're
doing so a blind alysus is a measurement
performed without looking at the answer
and is the optimal way to avoid
experimenters bias so to give you a
sense of what this looks like from a
physics perspective these are four
different physical measurement values
the actual measurements of them
particularly important but this is
published date versus the findings for
these these different values and you can
see that there's trends over time of
what the value is for these different
constants some of them start high and up
going low and so on and so forth and so
they started after realizing that people
are doing things like hey this looks
like it's a 3 Sigma effect compared to
what was published last year maybe we
got something wrong I don't go back and
double-check it
and so they'll double-check it when they
realize that it doesn't match the
previous one and maybe you look and you
find something in your analysis that oh
of course I did this wrong and you fix
it and it gets back to the right answer
you can start having these problems so
to keep yourself from doing this they
did a blinding analysis and excuse me
the there's a nature blog post about
about blinding analysis which has this
nice quote excuse me because many
analytical decisions and computer
programming bugs can't be anticipated
investigators are forced to make
decisions knowing either consciously or
unconsciously how their choices will
affect the measured result so you're
trying to measure the lifetime of a
particular may zone or something and you
know the answer it can lead to either
conscious or unconscious changes in that
value blinding analysis enables the
investigator to engage in the analysis
and exploration and finalization without
worrying about such advice since you
don't see the answer you can't be biased
toward what you think the right answer
is so to give you a concrete example of
what this means we'll give you a quick
interactive example
so this also comes in that same nature
blog post of line analysis to hide
results to seek the truth there's
different techniques blending techniques
you can add noise to the data you can
actually bias the sample in some way you
can scan below into this the details of
the actual techniques for it except to
show you one so here's just a simple
Python object called blinders and what
it's going to do is blind the result
from stats models so that when I'm doing
this analysis I can't know the answer so
let's say I wanted to do my own so I saw
the red card study from before and I
thought this was fantastic I wonder what
I would get for the same analysis I get
the data and I started working on it I
already know that say 20 of the results
were at like odds ratio of 1.3 so I kind
of have an idea of what the right answer
is right so if I simply and I mean
blinding this way like so I say the red
card propensity as a function of
skintone height and position let's say
those are the covariance I start with
and I run some or some logistic
regression or or near least squares when
I view the summary using the model dot
summary from stats models it shows you
everything every coefficient but in this
case if I say I want to blind myself to
the effect of skintone on this analysis
the analysis is still run everything
happens the only thing this blinding
thing does is print Nan's for this for
this row so everything about the
analysis is still done it's still in
that model object I've not changed the
values of anything this is just a
blinding for my effect so now that if I
decide do I want to continue to keep ad
position should I add weight perhaps or
height I know that when I'm if I'm
adding that to the model I'm making
these choices I'm not making it based on
what I know the variable to have an
answer for okay so the this particular
implementation I'll give you a link to
it at the end of the talk it's not that
important Mort what's more important is
the principle itself
alright so with that I'll go on to my
conclusions so conclusion 1 first of all
realize that science and data science
statistics and whatnot is actually
harder than you probably think it is
it's a really hard thing to do correctly
and acknowledge that be aware of this
garden of forking paths this problem
where you have multiple comparisons that
can be possible even if you want run
only a single analysis on your result
try to avoid just so stories consider
the opposite be explicit and trying to
be precise in what it would take to
change your mind from a particular
belief or strategy that you're currently
taking when possible try to blind your
analysis and whenever way you can so
that you're not unconsciously or so or
even consciously trying to get to the
right answer and a thing that I didn't
talk about is this thing called
threshold out which is a reusable
holdout set and I've provided some links
to this in this final thing here so
thank you very much this is my contact
information so Jonathan that's my email
address Twitter and the sources I put in
this in this talk I will also put up the
slides as well are all available at this
bitly link so if you go to this bitly
link you'll have sources to the blinders
code that I put in there and all these
other things so that one that's a
one-stop shop for your resources if you
saw something in the talk that's not in
there
it's send me a message on Twitter send
me an email and I'll add it to that list
thank you very much
you
hi great talk thanks very much my
question goes back to the analysis of
get lab merge requests okay I get up and
I just wondering what was the effect
size for the one gender difference they
found is it it seems to me like my
experience that often closely tied to P
Hawking is just reporting on results
that are not very big yes sir I'll use
the microphone so okay so the Y axis
goes from 60 percent this is 70 percent
so the first two tick marks between 60
and 70 it's an effect size between this
two this looks like about sixty two and
a half percent for women and it's priced
sixty three and a half for men so about
a 1% difference in the effect size that
the effect size has to be large I don't
know I think that might be too
restrictive of a requirement yeah okay
so I will say definitely that you should
strongly consider the effect size as
whether it's important or not definitely
so you can have a statistical
significance without it being
significant in in practice essentially
that is an important thing to keep in
mind I don't know that I'd use this as a
red flag to say that maybe you're doing
pee hacking or something though I'll
repeat the question so
yes
so I would just like to point out with
with a holdout set sometimes it depends
on the case cuz holdout sets could be
done for like say an internal company's
reasons so like you have a holdout set
that you run models and do a hyper
parameter fits on it to decide it so
you're actually running against the same
holdout set many many times and that
kind of a thing you're doing an
overfitting even though it's a holdout
set right so that's why I'd like to
actually highlight this just real quick
this work by Cynthia I'd work and a lot
of other people it's called the reusable
holdout threshold out and it is a way of
being able to in a statistically valid
way repeatedly look at a holdout sample
which is what people basically do anyway
so this is also included in that
resources thing at the end but one of
the quotes that they have from that
paper is that modern data analysis is
inherently adaptive so you just you
actually look at the answer many many
times one way to help yourself not get
driven it the wrong way is blinding
another way is to use a holdout set and
you're going to look at a holdout set
many times and you're you've thrown away
the reason for doing a holdout set so
threshold out is a very very cool idea I
think should get more attention
yeah so the question is is there a
preset like a canned way of doing an
analysis that you can just say this is
definitely right way to do it for some
say new data coming in have I seen that
kind of thing you could do that it's it
I think that comes into starting to be
almost report generation like you say
okay well what is this month's analysis
um once you have everything tweaked and
stuff I think once that is done it comes
out of science or data science and into
something as you said like engineering
or report generation which is very
useful as well that's just a different
thing any other questions
yeah
yes the question is how do I or how do
people in general learn this stuff from
the best way possible
I don't have besides reading widely and
trying to just figure out what's going
on and try to figure out what best
practices should be I don't have much
advice I mean so in astrophysics we also
have a similar kind of thing where you
just like you present results that are
minute like did you consider this have
you thought about that maybe you should
try your analysis but doing X Y Z right
so we have a similar kind of crucible of
fun let's call it when you give a talk
in and there's constructive criticism
going on to shore up your analytic chops
but outside of that just read as much as
you can sorry I don't have a better
answer
yeah
so how would you okay so the question is
how would you work on doing analysis
where there is multiple splits on the
data set and so on and so forth well one
way you can do this is to actually put
these in a regression that allows for
either like Simpsons paradox kind of
thing to be teased out for this so that
you're having an overall effect plus an
effect on the various things you're
concerned about holding constant or or
doing so that that's at least one
approach for that kind of thing more
specific than that I don't I don't have
advice but so anytime you're using the
data itself to drive your analytic
decisions you're in trouble you're in
you're in danger zone you're not
necessarily definitely do something
wrong it's just like there's a blinking
red light over your head and it should
be blinking louder as you keep going so
I think doing like regression multiple
like that helps as well as planning the
analysis I think with blinding you at
least know that you're not going toward
a result you have a preconceived notion
for that you trying to find if I get
this I get a publication if I get a no
result nothing right so I think that can
help and good luck it's hard thank you
very much Jonathan with more data
scientist at Silicon Valley data science